six months after the new Mercedes
c-class sedan was launched it's being
joined on the catwalk by the T model
station wagon variant like its sibling
the latest Benz has a lot in common with
the car makers luxury models
so what does the T in T model stand for
anyway such a cred says that the first
team Apple came out 14 years ago and the
letter in the name stands for transport
and tourism to key space concepts the
brand had plan for the car for the
seventies home concept and that first T
model back in 1977 was revolutionary in
how it made use of space this animated
ad shows how versatile the Mercedes T
was for transporting lots of people and
lots of cargo the T model was the first
in a long line of what Mercedes called
its lifestyle station wagons it put paid
to the image of the body style as a kind
of closed bed truck our car tester Sacha
Kopp says that more than half of the
c-class cars sold are T models
he likes the features like the one that
allows you to open the trunk even when
your hands are full
the trunk is slightly larger in the new
model Sascha says he now has almost 500
liters of volume with the backseat down
that triples and lowering it is easy if
the front seats are so far back that
they would block it the system shifts
them forward automatically then in back
you have a loading surface that's almost
completely flat and you can fit in
objects up to one meter eighty long only
toxic languaging Stern and laden come
that's not the whole car is ten
centimeters longer now it's around 4
meters 70 in total those 10 centimetres
improve passenger comfort in the
backseat says Sascha there's really
plenty of knee room now just like past
models the interior has a high-end field
the T model comes equipped with lots of
assistance programs and as always with
Mercedes the workmanship is top-notch
the very first T models offered leather
seats as an extra and of course that
hasn't changed
Sascha Kratt says the car is a lifestyle
product with great proportions that
handles well the design has gotten
rounder but it's still based on the
classic concept you can see that in the
rear he says the most important area in
a model like this you can still fit ten
cases of drinks in there the new T model
is also 65 kilograms lighter which
Mercedes managed by making many of the
components out of aluminium like the
hood for example the lighter weight has
an effect on fuel economy as well says
Sascha the motors could be made on
average 20% more efficient we took out
the 250 T model it packs a hundred and
fifty-five kilowatts of power under the
hood and can hit 100 kilometres an hour
from a dead stop in just 6.8 seconds its
top speed is 244 kilometres an hour with
the c-class says andreas Hefner T model
customers can communicate with the car
on their smartphones via a web-based
application through a Mercedes website
the customer has direct access to what's
called Daimler vehicle back-end a secure
IT system where you can view the data on
your car here for example you can see
the current fuel levels they're updated
every time the vehicle is turned on or
off says heaven it lets you know whether
you'll definitely be able to make it
back home on what's left in the tank or
if you really do have to stop and fuel
up
you could also use the system to check
whether you forgot to lock up if you did
that you can do so without having to
return to the car
and if you forgot where you parked don't
worry Daimler vehicle back-end knows
where your ride is overall our car
tester was favorably impressed that's
noisy Class A team well the new c-class
team model is aimed at those who have to
transport people or stuff but want to do
it in style says Sascha but it doesn't
come cheap bare-bones versions of the
car start at 35,000 euros in Germany and
the C 250 will put you back forty
thousand it's not the cheapest solution
out there